ladies and gentlemen we have ourselves a
trailer i was not expecting for
enchanted to enchant harder
it's called
disenchanted it's going to disney plus
which surprises me because we got word
that the original cast is all going to
be here i'm like why is this not in the
theaters then
but john how are you i am wonderful how
are you
[Music]
what in god's name are you possibly
doing embarrassing us both ladies and
gentlemen leave a like the first
enchanted is amazing amazing movie so
let's just see what this trailer
[Music]
i know the change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
if i learned anything from meeting
princess on a billboard is that
sometimes you just have to take a leap
let's start our new life
okay
monroeville
it's all part of the adventure
that's not an adventure that's a
landfill a land filled with adventure
edwards
oh it's what they call a fixer-upper yes
once your peasants have dug out the moat
and added a turret and a balcony from
which you can sing i see it now oh okay
[Music]
melvina monroe i wouldn't buy a rudolph
but i deal in slightly more upscale
homes oh
in the andalasia the hardest part of
life is finding your happily ever after
this world is very different
if this world is not to your liking then
you must change it i wish
what are you gonna do
gonna bring a little andalesia here
[Music]
he's talking man
i wish for a fairytale life and it's all
gone terribly wrong or terribly right
little both
at the last stroke of 12 nothing will be
as it was before
[Music]
whoa
we're going dark
what have you done
a wicked wicked good
she's so good at that
i know
[Music]
i did not think i'd be saying this but
i got a case of the nipple chills oh
that was
chilling your heart is warm but you're
going to see a true white shirt for sure
yeah no i don't even need to do a touch
test
that
looks great it looks lovely like i mean
you know the last one was it was so much
more like exploring new york city and
such and this is much more of an
isolated location yeah now
but of course there's still going to be
some adventure to explore as you're
seeing you're hopping in between you
know the what is that place like ando
and elasia um and you see that they will
probably hop between them but it's going
to be taking more of like a cinderella
riff this time around stepmother riff
yeah it feels like it but yeah i mean
what's what's cool about this because
they're calling it disenchanted is that
that first movie ends you know as you'd
expect a happily ever after type of
ending and then it's picking up with
these characters you know however many
years later showing it hasn't exactly
been like their their romance in the
family like that the main core of them
has been loving and full of high spirits
but the life there has not been as
happily ever after so then there's such
that theme of learning about the real
world and adulthood factoring back into
the gisele character and then uh being a
parent as well
and watching how that influence takes
hold in the suburbia lifestyle i i don't
know i was actually like really
surprised by
how much how well it actually looked and
everyone just slips back into their role
so well despite the fact that they're
like more aware of their age um they
they seem like they're just doing a
great like amy adam just freaking like
nailing oh there's always james bartson
just freaking like bam it's awesome
there's something that's that is really
exciting and did it seem like it was
just nostalgia heavy trailer too like it
was really moving the story forward yeah
well it hearkened to a lot of you know
disney things as the first enchanted
does it plays on your knowledge of all
the tropes and all the imagery and the
iconography but i thought that this was
like a really conscientious follow-up
because yeah like you know you have that
happily ever after big sweeping ending
but what happens when you are living in
a place that isn't quite suited to you
and that is sort of a grueling work a
day world and so yeah this this need to
remove yourself and to go out to the
country and to bring a little bit of
home you know to
our earth in this case but yeah you know
bring a little bit of your home to this
new place that you're transplanted to
like it does look like a genuine story
to tell and then you can have all the
fun on top of that and too i love the
blending of you know you have the cg
creep creations and you have things like
that scroll that's talking to her like
those whimsical magical disney things
but you also have some of that 2d splash
as well uh with prince edward at one
point which i hope becomes like a
full-on sequence or something because i
think one thing that enchanted is really
great at is not only deconstructing the
disney tropes but also celebrating the
tradition of that kind of you know very
grand and
beautiful sort of opulent story
uh about timeless romance and stuff like
that but also too i i imagine there's a
lot to say about how much work it is to
maintain that romance even uh as well as
you know just a life that you can feel
at home in and feel you know enchanted
by yeah they're going to get things
kinky up and dis chanted man
she's gonna
trade her her uh ball gown in for
something latex well you know like that
last one uh
if i recall correctly because it's been
a very very very long time since i've
seen enchanted i just remember really
being surprised by how much i enjoyed it
uh that that one
didn't seem i don't remember the
trailers leaning into the darkness that
the movie could actually do like there
is a fun darkness to be had here
especially with mix because it could
have just been amy adams giselle doing
that like funny
know what like she has that line in
there
about oh what's something about the home
and that was there's a funny line in um
the landfill the atlanta it's a landfill
no it's a land filled with enchantments
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i thought like the trailer would just be
a lot more of those jokes but to see amy
adams gizelle get that a chance to do a
darker side of it i think is great and
the addition of maya rudolph i think is
excellent yes you know i wish they
didn't reveal i know i wish it didn't
show like oh damn she actually has some
type of uh magical connection to some
evil woman
because i i think they they could have
alluded or hinted that better but i
would have liked to have let that just
kind of unless the movie clues you in
right away then they haven't spoiled
anything yeah
but if they don't then i'm like it's
kind of a bummer that they would show
that but again the production design
looks excellent i'm excited for the
musical numbers i'm excited for this
cast to return and overall just this
actually looks like a genuinely great
time and i like that it doesn't feel
like remember the last one yeah yeah
it's an actual story and uh if i recall
like pip makes a comment here about how
is he actually talking because that's
part of the joke with the first one yeah
when pip comes to the real world he
can't speak yeah uh so something's uh
hey the magic's bleeding over and
that'll be fun to see you know how they
justify the change in rules and things
like that and how the magic has shifted
powerful magic man powerful magic if
you're bringing andalesia here i'm
hoping that the new cast especially the
family uh gets a chance to shine though
too yeah because it seems like the
daughter is going to be a heavy focus i
imagine they're going to do a lot more
themes about parenting and like
because clearly there's aspects of it
that feel like it's playing on like evil
stepmother or cinderella yeah and so i
do want them to to see a little bit more
of that like the difficulties of
parenting cinderella thrust into the
position of having to be mom and
disciplinary well you know you have
gizelle who is uh
a woman who comes from a disney fairy
tale land and then she has a daughter
born in the real world and so there's
got to be a lot of budding heads yeah
over how the they view things you know
wish fulfillment versus reality
yeah you could totally imagine gisele
trying to teach her just things like
trying to summon animal friends to help
you via song and that may be perhaps not
working yeah yeah yeah things like that
so i'm looking forward to it but guys
what'd you think about a disenchanted
trailer leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell i think a
little mermaid drops so we gotta we
gotta talk about that too
[Music]